fake martial arts are incredibly
dangerous Frank Ducks was a legendary
fighter he must compete in the Kum it
was supposedly a longstanding tournament
where the greatest martial artists from
all over the world came and fought to
their death Ducks traveled to the
Bahamas sought out the tournament and
began the fight to honor his master's
Legacy Ducks became the first ever
Westerner to win the tournament after
this Ducks returned to the Army and
began undertaking covert hops both for
the military and the CIA he also began
forming his own martial arts schools it
was during this time that his incredible
story became more widely known and was
even the basis for the jeanclaude Von
Dam movie Blood Sport for which Ducks
was hired to be the fight coordinator
the most incredible thing about Frank
Ducks is that it's all complete
he made it all up